donc vous débarquez dans les bistrots à
l'heure de l'apéro en disant bonjour
c'est la société Ricard tournée générale
c'était la carte de visite
alors vous pouvez pas boire un diabolo
menthe ou une verveine vous êtes obligé
de boire du Ricard avec les gens qui
boivent du Ricard déjà il est difficile
voilà de pouvoir trinquer avec un verre
autre que le produit que vous proposez
du samedi 20h ce soir Franck Daniel
bonsoir
[Musique]
accompagné avocat Maître mon tour si
bonsoir
alors Franck aujourd'hui Pernod Ricard
et numéro 1 mondial de la vente de vins
et spiritueux mais derrière cette
fabuleuse réussite se cache une armée de
représentants qui font le tour de tous
les comptoirs du monde pour faire
déguster les produits cette vie vous
l'avez vécu pendant 11 ans le corps
imbibé de Ricard en permanence vous y
avez laissé votre santé votre famille et
votre mariage vous êtes le héros d'un
livre d'Eric coder publié chez Max
Millau intitulé dis-leur légal ou vous
raconter vos 11 ans passés chez Ricard à
faire boire des coups si votre boulot et
ça vous a coûté votre santé votre
famille et votre mariage
alors vous êtes né le 14 novembre 1966 à
Fontenay-aux-Roses dans le 92 votre père
était un chanteur raté VRP pour des
revues techniques automobiles toujours
en vadrouille aux quatre coins de France
rarement à la maison et votre mère va
élever le mieux possible ces trois
garçons dans une HLM sans trop compter
sur l'argent du père elle en pleurait
souvent votre mère de San an comme toute
mère qui essaye d'élever ses enfants
avec Rayan
c'était dur mais ça nous a pris avoir de
certaines valeurs
c'est pour cela qu'à 14 ans vous décidez
de travailler ce qui vous oblige à
falsifier votre carte d'identité parce
qu'il faut avoir 16 ans alors votre père
est d'accord à condition que vous
reversiez la moitié de votre salaire à
votre mère c'était la condition
sinequanone pour lui il veut partir du
principe dans ce qu'on travaillait il
fallait ramener de l'argent à la maison
alors vous commencez comme vendeur de
pommes de terre puis vous êtes commis
dans une crèmerie mais rapidement vos
ambitions s'affirment vous voulez
devenir quelqu'un
j'ai voulu surtout ressembler à une
personne libre et moi la liberté c'était
d'être représentant alors après un CAP
de commercial et un BEP de vendeur vous
trouvez un job dans une boutique du
sentier et là vous découvrez les
rudiments du métier de vendeur
c'est-à-dire quand on met que vous
achète un costume vous lui donnez une
cravate une ceinture enfin vous
comprenez comment ça marche quoi savoir
donner pour vendre plus un bon client
c'est un client qui revient qui revient
avec le sourire
ensuite vous vendrez des pantalons des
aspirateurs des extincteurs du papier
hygiénique toujours avec la même ferveur
peu importe le produit et c'est là que
vous voyez dans Le Nouvel Observateur
une annonce de la société Ricard qui
cherche des représentants alors vous
avez pas le bac + 2 mais vous y allez
quand même vous dites c'était la chance
de ma vie je suis rentré dans cette
grande
dès les premiers échanges les recruteurs
vérifient que vous aimez le ricard bien
sûr on peut pas on peut pas promouvoir
un produit si on n'aime pas le produit
vous êtes engagé vous épousez Guylaine
donc la mère de vos enfants et là il y a
l'épreuve du crash test c'est à dire
qu'on vous invite à la foire au fromage
à Coulommiers sur le stand Ricard et en
deux heures vous enfilez 20 apéros comme
si de rien n'était
c'est une mise à l'épreuve me concernant
et vous réussissez très bien
en arrêtant dormir dans la voiture oui
le lendemain le patron vous appelle pour
vous féliciter tout va pour le mieux
alors le boulot vous plaît vous gérez
800 clients que vous devez voir une fois
tous les trois mois l'objectif c'est
d'écouler 300 bouteilles par jour c'est
beaucoup mais bon ça fait pas ça faisait
partie du travail donc vous débarquez
dans les bistrots à l'heure de l'apéro
en disant bonjour c'est la société
Ricard tournée générale c'était la carte
de visite
alors vous pouvez pas boire un diabolo
menthe ou une verveine vous êtes obligé
de boire du Ricard avec les gens qui
boivent du Ricard déjà il est difficile
voilà de pouvoir trinquer avec un verre
autre que le produit que vous proposez
alors vous payez votre tournée puis il y
a de l'assurance air le patron paye la
sienne à partir du moment où on crée une
convivialité donc on oblige déjà une
personne à rentrer dans notre jeu et
après automatiquement la personne veut
nous rendre l'appareil donc on ne peut
pas refuser
c'est un cercle vicieux vicieux alors
pendant 11 ans vous allez boire 20 à 30
verres par jour
quand vous arrivez chez vous vers 21h
vous êtes crevés vous avez pas trop la
force de discuter avec votre femme
on évite on évite de parler de ces
choses-là elles le sentait
et vous endormez la tête un peu embrumée
des vapeurs de Ricard et surtout en
train de préparer la journée après à
venir oui parce que vous êtes au boulot
à 6h30 le lendemain matin à l'ouverture
des bars
alors évidemment votre patron vous adore
moi aussi
quand ça va pas ils vous remonte le
moral c'est une famille de temps en
temps il vous sortent un peu dans les
boîtes à la mode il vous faut rencontrer
des gens connus donc finalement vous
êtes totalement heureux je vivais
quelque chose que je n'aurais jamais pu
vivre
en temps normal
quand il y a des vacances et dans le
centre d'hébergement du comité
d'entreprise donc nourri leger blanchi
alors vous possédez à fond votre
technique de vente alors je sais pas si
c'est des choses qu'on vous explique ou
si c'est vous qui découvrez tout seul
mais vous dites faites-vous un ami par
jour c'était les propos du fondateur
donc je l'appliquais à la lettre c'est
pas compliqué de se faire des amis à
partir du moment où on peut boire avec
la personne discuter de certaines choses
personnelles misez sur la force sociale
de l'alcool pour inciter à la
consommation
alors le problème
c'est comment conduire
ivre à longueur de journée pendant 11
ans sans y laisser son permis de
conduire et là vous découvrez qu'il
suffit de se faire des amis dans la
police en leur offrant des millionnaires
moi sur mon secteur je savais comment
rentrer tranquille donc je savais
contacter certaines personnes et leur
préparer les apéritifs aussi parce
qu'ils ont des pots de départ donc vous
achetiez les flics en fait
avec les autorités
il est assez terrible parce que comme
Ricard est une marque qui vieillit à un
moment la société décide de vous
demander de cibler les jeunes voilà vous
mettez en jean en santiag vous remettez
un petit brillant dans l'oreille vous
rasez la boule pour faire jeune quoi
pour attaquer un nouveau marché voilà
savoir se fondre dans la foule ne pas
être différent de
voilà vous organisez des karaokés dans
les bars dans les clubs pour forcer les
jeunes à boire en fait pour leur faire
connaître le produit
vous êtes sûr qu'ils étaient majeurs les
clients qui étaient là je n'ai jamais
demandé leur pièce d'identité
alors il y a aussi les soirées
étudiantes là c'est une bouteille
gratuite pour 3 acheter c'est sympa sauf
qu'il faut acheter 600 bouteilles
de 100 bouteilles gratuites et ensuite
il faut il faut y couler la marchandise
voilà vous donner des carafes des
gobelets des jeux des cadeaux il y a des
hôtesses enfin tout ça est très marketé
c'est le but le but c'était de
donner une bonne image de l'entreprise
un jour quand même après une animation
comme ça vous faites traiter l'assassin
par qui c'est Monsieur que je ne
connaissais pas
j'ai pas demandé à le connaître plus je
suis rentré dans ma voiture tout
simplement ça vous a fait réfléchir
absolument pas je n'étais pas un
associant j'étais un homme pour amener
du plaisir moi je voyais pas le mal
alors voilà désormais vous êtes chargé à
longueur de journée vous êtes imbibé par
par le ricard vous sentez le ricard
vaudra sans le ricard baigner là-dedans
alors un jour votre femme quand même
finit par craquer elle fait une
dépression très grave leviez pas senti
venir ça non
pour sentir les choses venir il faut
être présent j'étais souvent absent du
domicile conjugal alors à l'époque c'est
vrai que vous travaillez du lundi au
vendredi donc de 6h30 à 14h ensuite
faites une petite sieste dans la voiture
et vous reprenez à 20h jusqu'à l'aube et
pour démarrer le matin les jours où
c'est un peu compliqué à 6h30 vous
faites un petit ricard quoi voilà je me
donne la force nous vous rendez compte à
l'époque que vous êtes alcoolique non
absolument pas absolument pas et même
mon ex-épouse
c'est pouvait pas m'en parler parce que
je me considérais pas comme un
alcoolique voilà là vous vous mettez à
vomir du sang
et un jour et là c'est terrible dans
votre voiture vous commencez à vous
vider de votre sang par l'anus vos cinq
terres ont lâché vous avez une
hémorragie anale
l'intestin était bouffé par la Ricard
l'intestin était abîmée maintenant il
n'y a aucun lien
qui a été prouvé que c'était lié au
Ricard vous dites ça parce que votre
avocat
je lui dis ça parce que
je ne suis pas là pour un criminer qui
que ce soit ni
ce que j'ai fait je l'ai fait j'ai eu la
chance de subi les conséquences là à
cette époque-là vous retrouvez avec des
couches pour adultes vous reprenez le
boulot faites une grosse fête de 3 jours
là il y a un ricard a racheté une marque
de jean espagnole vous y allez buvez
pendant trois jours non stop
je vous retrouve à l'hosto
et quelques mois plus tard vous êtes
licenciés pourquoi vous vendez moins de
Ricard
non parce que je suis tombé malade
alors votre plus gros combat reste à
venir c'est le sevrage très très dur
voilà vous cachez des mignonnettes dans
le jardin et puis quand vous avez envie
vous habitez une ferme avec une il y
avait une grange une écurie je cachais
tout à droite à gauche
puis vous prenez des cachets
vous avez pris 1400 cachets en un an
et vous arrivez à oublier l'alcool avec
tout ça
non
c'est abrutis plus qu'autre chose mais
si vous enlève pas l'envie
un jour vous essayez de vous suicider
avec une boîte de Lexomil passer deux
jours dans le coma je me suis trompé au
lieu de prendre justement de l'alcool
avec les xobi j'ai pris de l'eau sinon
vous seriez mort vous croyez si j'avais
pris de la colle avec oui bien sûr
alors là à ce moment-là votre femme elle
peut plus quoi elle prend les deux mots
sous le bras et elle s'en va chez sa
mère
j'accepte
et vous aussi vous retournez chez votre
mère
pas obligation retour à la case départ
c'est dur ça c'est dur mais bon
c'était le prix à payer
j'étais à la rue
j'avais plus rien donc c'était voilà à
m'as sauvé alors voilà vous avez
rencontré une autre femme vous habitez à
Grasse
je peux pas les juger je peux pas les
juger est-ce que moi-même en tant que
papa j'ai eu le comportement idéal
est-ce que j'étais présent quand elles
avaient besoin de moi pour moi je
pensais simplement que pouvoir acheter
ce que je pouvais pour un ce qu'elle
voulait suffisait en fin de compte non
un enfant a besoin aussi d'amour de
communication c'est le cas de beaucoup
de papa
alors ce bouquin Ricard a essayé de le
faire interdire
comment ça se fait qu'il soit pas
interdit
alors là je pense que depuis que je
connais Monsieur Daniel il y a eu deux
procès consécutifs à ce livre la suite
Ricard a perdu le premier procès devant
le tribunal suite à peine elle a perdu
on appelle le second procès la suite à
l'écart a formé un pourvoi en question
actuellement et au-delà des antagonistes
que nous pouvons avoir sur le fond
puisque je défends la liberté
d'expression de Monsieur Daniel et la
suite Ricard cherche à restreindre cette
liberté d'expression je tiens à celui à
saluer la dignité des débats qui ont eu
lieu puisque chacun apportait des
éléments de preuves Monsieur Daniel a
apporté des attestations des notes
internes de la société Ricard qui ont
jusqu'à présent dans le cadre de ces
deux procès permis au juge de considérer
comme c'est Daniel était de bonne foi
j'ai l'impression de me voir quand
j'avais arrêté mon traitement alcoolique
personnel parce que j'étais allé assez
loin dans le truc avec des Bourbons
américains etc mais très vite ouais j'ai
du m'arrêter pareil et on est brisé on
ressort de là on est calciné on a tous
les nerfs à vif et on est détruit on est
un mec détruit parce que l'alcool était
notre fondement évidemment on avait un
coup dur vu ils vont un coup il se
passait un truc bien rebuvons un autre
coup etc et quand on vous arrache ça
soudain vous êtes une écorce de bonhomme
c'est plus trop qu'est-ce que ce que
vous faites dans la société surtout
quand vous sortez que vous entendez les
gens boire et soudain le son monté comme
un Boeing qui décolle et vous vous êtes
là au sol à dire oui qu'est-ce qui se
passe
c'est affreux et c'est vachement
difficile quand on est moi-même j'étais
dans un métier les gens rentraient dans
mon bureau ça surprenait personne qui a
une bouteille de Bourbon sur le bureau
une bière
effectivement au bout de 10 ans le corps
moi mon corps pareil a dit non il faut
qu'on arrête là l'expérience est
terminée quoi c'est combien de temps
vous n'avez pas vu
mais pas une goutte très bien merci de
votre témoignage en tous les cas et pour
être sûr de ne rien rater de tube
abonnez-vous et mettez un pouce bleu